BEST GOALIE, WITH WASHINGTON AND
ROOKIE ALEX NEDELIJKOVIC
STARTING IN THEM IN.
KEN: AND THE
DeKEYSER.
THIS IS PAVELSKI, THEIR TEAM
LEADER IN GOALS, ASSISTS ANDES D
FOR THE RED WINGS, AND FIVE OF
THEM ON THE ROAD, THREE LIKE TH.
THEY FEEL THAT NET,
JUST SHOOT IT WITH ALL THAT YOU
HAVE GOT, SUTER. SEASON KIVIRANR
YOU AND NEDELIJKOVIC, HIS BODY K
FOR GURIANOV, GETTING IT TURNEDR
THERE AT THE DETROIT NOW IT IS N
ERRANT PASS, KLINGBERG, NEARLY D
STEAMED DOWNBERG.NATE.
AND SEIDER, READY THERE.
BACK TO MY, PAVELSKI, GOING
FARSIDE THERE, JAMMING IT ASSIS.
FOR HITS LINDELL
AND GOES INTO
THING THAT IT WAS ONE
SEGUIN, SLOT, BLOCKED IN SEIDERE
DOWN AT THE BLUE LINE.
AND I THINK HELP HIM.AVEL DATSYN
LARKIN
FOR "RED WINGS LIVE" FROM
BROADWAY IN NASHVILLE AND A LONG
ACROSS.
OFF OF THE HANDLE AND Y